ja also ich frage mich wie sollen
unternehmer wie soll der deutsche
mittelstand noch vertrauen in die
politik haben wenn sogar die spd oder
sogar der bürgerlich wirkende olaf
scholz das bündnis mit den linken nicht
mehr ausschließt es wird doch immer
klarer scholz ist das trojanische pferd
der spd und wer scholz wählt bekommt das
weltbild von saskia esken und kevin
kühnert und die linken nach oben mit
drauf dazu und folgen würde die folgen
davon wären steuererhöhungen
enteignungen verbote bevormundung und
generell auch eine abkehr von unserer
sehr erfolgreichen sozialen
marktwirtschaft die unser land unser
deutschland eigentlich zu dem gemacht
hat wo wir heute stehen zu wohlstand
gebracht hat und unsere wirtschaft zum
florieren gebracht hat und sind wir doch
mal ganz ehrlich verhältnisse wie in
venezuela oder kuba oder gar in der ddr
will doch heute niemand mehr haben und
die ganzen sozialistischen ideen sind in
den ländern wirklich haben sich zu einem
albtraum entpuppt und eine solche
politik der steuererhöhungen der verbote
würde unsere standortpolitik hier in
deutschland massiv schädigen und
gefährden unsere wettbewerbsfähigkeit
stehen würde auf dem spiel stehen
zahlreiche unternehmer würden das
vertrauen in die politik aber auch ein
verlust von arbeitsplätzen
wahrscheinlich von sich ziehen und
würden auch ins ausland abwandern weil
es hier einfach nicht mehr
wirtschaftlich zu machen ist und das
würde natürlich wieder dazu führen dass
wir auch arbeitsplätze und wohlstand
verlieren und deswegen sage ich ganz
klar ein land kann nur funktionieren
wenn die wirtschaft einnahmen generiert
und fakt ist eine linke regierung wird
arbeitsplätze und wohlstand gefährden
ja ich stimme dir teilweise zu also ich
glaube man kann olaf scholz nicht den
vorwurf machen dass er ein bündnis mit
den grünen nicht mit dem ständig aus
geschlossen hat was mir definitiv zum
vorwurf machen kann ist das sehr links
wird genau
das also erst nicht ausgeschlossen er
hat das nicht wirklich ausgeschlossen
hat sich klar positioniert und gesagt
man mit diesen extremisten werde ich
nicht coliona und das ist natürlich was
ich eingangs gesagt habe wie können wir
als unternehmer als deutscher
mittelstand ich repräsentiere junge
familien unternehmer in deutschland wie
können wir noch vertrauen haben in eine
politik mit er keine klaren und
transparenten
aussagen auch bekommen dass wenn wir ein
kanzlerkandidat scholz oder die spd
wählen da womöglich noch das weltbild
von saskia in unserem keller in der
natur spd
bild.de leser oder war da also passieren
wie du spd ja also ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen einer familie jemand sbb gewählt
so weit ich mich erinnern kann nicht
aber ich muss sagen also die spd damals
war ja wirklich so diese aufsteiger
partei dass er durch die arbeit der
partei dass wenn ich richtig schaffen
die ärmel hochkrempeln dass ich auch
hier unterstützung bekommen auch als
werden kann dieses leistungsprinzip was
ich so jetzt heute nicht mehr sehen die
spd hat sich sehr ins linke spektrum
weiter bewegt und die basis deutlich
linker als der kanzlerkandidat olaf
scholz und das macht natürlich vielen
unternehmern bauchschmerzen weil man
nicht weiß was man am ende zu erwarten
hat wo ich jetzt muss ich habe heute
mittag ein interview geführt mit jessica
rosenthal sie ist die vorsitzende der
jusos auf kevin finnland gefolgt wir
haben heute ein livestream gehabt und
ich fand sie sehr sympathisch
sympathische ausstrahlung aber mich hat
sehr schockiert ihr wissenschaftliches
wissen also wir haben über mieten deckel
diskutiert und über andere sachen und da
bin ich schon etwas schockiert dass das
gefühl teile ich bei der spd dass ich
das gefühl habe dass heutzutage
inklusive olaf scholz nicht mehr genug
auf die wirtschaft geschaut wird
geachtet auch nicht genug verständnis
davon herrscht aber ich glaube damit du
die spd wird es muss mehr als 10 11 und
abscheu endlich sagt er geht nicht mit
den linken zusammen du kommst kritisch
sonst ist es richtig es bleibt die acht
große achillesferse von olaf scholz
solange er sicht oder anderen spd sich
nicht erklären wie sie es mit der
linkspartei halten ist das eine offene
flanke in die natürlich die gegner immer
rein stoßen auch müssen sehr wichtig
denn wer so wenig zustimmung hat der
nimmt das was irgendwie geht und das ist
halt das was noch geht erinnert mich ein
bisschen an alten spruch von helmut kohl
in der lange ist sehr ein parteitag
gesagt haben 1975 habe es auch nur
nachgelesen was nützt die beste
sozialpolitik wenn die kosaken kommen
also die große gefahr dass feind kommt
irgendwo daher und die erste kohorte ist
kevin kühnert die zweite saskia esken
und dann wird unser land überrannt kein
unternehmer mit mehr geld aus dem
unternehmen wobei das eigentlich eine
forderung ist der grünen keine gewinne
mehr raus zu nehmen ich weiß nicht wie
man das den startup leuten sagen kann
die alle auch darauf setzen die
unternehmen groß zu machen und dann
irgendwann zu verkaufen aber da sollte
man vielleicht auch mal hingucken also
das bleibt nach release verse für olaf
scholz und solange er das nicht geklärt
hat muss er sich das anhören gerade auch
nachdem die linkspartei von war es
letzte woche die in afghanistan hilfe
der afghanistan hilfe nicht zugestimmt
hat also muss man sagen die partei hat
sich endgültig disqualifiziert und da
kam ich auch sagen eigentlich mit den
wollen wir nicht allzu schwer eigentlich
ist es nicht so ich habe die ganze zeit
mehr kritik an die spd rhein gehört dass
an die linke also kevin kühnert und
masken und co also ist die frage ist ob
tatsächlich olaf scholz so viele weitere
optionen hat wenn er kanzler werden will
also der muss ja auch strategisch
schauen wenn er dann möglicherweise eine
ampelkoalition vielleicht führen wir das
auch strategisch ein gewischt hat eine
alternative zumindest eine tasche hat
und ich glaube dass er
ganz genau wenn er diese frage nicht
beantwortet auch diese option sich offen
hält wie gut oder wie schlecht sie für
uns nachher am ende des tages ist wird
sich zeigen ich glaube dass die angst
sehr groß ist berechtigter weise in
einigen bereichen in anderen bereichen
kann das auch eine chance für
deutschland sein aber ich als
unternehmer hätte wahrscheinlich auch
mehr sorgen als als als freude wenn ich
wusste dass da diese konstellation
zustande kommt ich persönlich habe aber
tatsächlich auch mit mit dem ja
parteichefs und mit den anderen den spd
momentan sehr ruhig sind und ich
überhaupt nicht weiß wofür sie stehen
damit habe ich auch ganz viel sorgen
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen bei dem
vermutlich auch ministeramt bekommen ich
habe das
und das und das ist für mich die größere
unsicherheiten im ganzen spiel also das
nochmal die linke mal weg aber wenn die
spd tatsächlich ankommt wer wird denn da
neben olaf scholz der für uns alle
berechenbar ist
noch verantwortung übernehmen und das
wäre das ist nämlich noch eine
unabhängig von dieser konstellation eine
ganz spannende fragen die große
ungewissheit während dann aber deswegen
auch das bild des trojanischen pferdes
ja olaf scholz mag bürgerlich wirken und
kommt gut bei den leuten an man sieht
sie einen umfrage werden aber wer sitzt
nachher mit am kabinettstisch und es
wird ein kevin kühnert eine saskia esken
ein walter-borjans und noch weitere die
ist sehr stark links eingestellt sind
viel linker als ein olaf scholz und das
macht mir natürlich sorgen weil wir
haben das thema wir haben jetzt eine
lange zeit der korona pandemie der krise
hinter uns befinden uns noch mitten drin
ich repräsentiere mit den
familienunternehmen zusammen über
sechseinhalb 1000 familienunternehmen in
deutschland aller branchen aus der
hotellerie aus dem messebau die sehr
stark getroffen sind und wenn ich
natürlich jetzt die programme lese und
da muss ich sagen die grünen die spd die
linke da sieht man schon so ein bisschen
den roten faden also ähnliche themen mit
steuererhöhungen mit dem thema
vermögenssteuer die erhöhung der
erbschaftssteuer und alles das würde den
deutschen mittelstand unsere familien
unternehmen im markt treffen weil wir
sind doch wir haben durch diese
besonderheit in deutschland des
deutschen mittelstandes über
generationen hinweg nachhaltig zu
wirtschaften
unser vermögen steckt in den betrieben
dadurch können wir auch arbeitsplätze
sichern weiter investieren in große
themen wie klimaschutz oder
digitalisierung und durch solche
gedanken mit steuererhöhungen
vermögenssteuer erbschaftssteuer
entzieht man den betriebenen
familienunternehmen das kapital und wie
sollen wir uns denn jetzt nach einer
gebeutelten corona krise wieder da
rausarbeiten wenn wir jetzt noch mehr
belastungen bekommen anstatt entlastung
wäre nicht immer mit gerd schröder
kommen aber die letzte steuerreform in
diesem land hat gerhard schröder
gekommen die wir die spd wieder
die spd der heutigen zeit hat probleme
wegen der agenda 2010 nicht wegen der
steuerreform und das ist auch hat ja
auch zudem quasi auflösende steuer
geworden bin die arrogante machen wollen
ja es gibt ja keine jetzt seitdem
insofern ist hier die frage was dann
passiert und ich glaube man sollte nicht
so tun als wären wir in den letzten 16
jahren hier unter dem segel der
wirtschaftsförderung durch deutschland
durch das durch durch die die gegenwart
gesegelt sondern im gegenteil es gibt ja
für die wirtschaft unglaublich viele
baustellen die wirtschaft ja auch
artikuliert wo was geschehen muss
digitalisierung ist das eine hier fehlt
es an einem wirtschaftsprogramm der sie
aber nirgendwo richtig sehe auch nicht
auf der seite die sie vielleicht vor
produzieren das problem ist hier glaube
ich ich glaube wenn ich dich richtig
wirksam reichtum ist ja nicht immer nur
mit shampoo scampi und porsche
gleichzusetzen das ist ja oft in der
deutschen gesellschaft wird das ja ganz
gerne immer gleichgesetzt aber es stimmt
natürlich die familienunternehmen sind
ja schon hinten champions wir brauchen
unternehmer wir brauchen auch das
leistungsprinzip was ich eine spd
schwieriger geht es dem besitzer einer
fabrik aber ein bisschen besser als dem
jeweiligen erzählt übrig am band stehen
er trägt auch die verantwortung bei der
der das einzige was ich hier noch sagen
wer ist bela weil du gesagt hast keiner
hat die wirtschaft im blick die spd will
er war ja schon die vermögenssteuer
wieder einführen das ist einer der
punkte die vermögenssteuer wurde 1997
abgeschafft in deutschland in frankreich
ist das experiment gerade auch
gescheitert die unternehmer werden
abwandern ich will mich jetzt nicht auf
die seite rüber schlagen aber ich glaube
das sind noch dinge die man
berücksichtigen kann
[Musik]